it's exciting and i think i'm a black
woman i identify as a black woman i
think people think well oh you know
maybe it's just like we've got to make
sure the black people are right or maybe
the latinx i'm like no no no
it is all of these groups who need a
strategic plan to make sure they're
included in the workforce
and that takes intentionality welcome to
20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funding silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm honored to have with me
kimberly b
cummings founder of manifest yourself
kimberly b cummings is a career and
leadership expert whose mission is to
help women and people of color
navigate the workplace make more money
and become industry leaders
her personal and professional
development company manifest yourself
llc
provides organizations with tailor-made
solutions to hire
develop engage and retain women and
people of color
her work has been featured on forbes
money magazine
teen vogue glassdoor cnbc fox 5 and more
kimberly is a graduate of long island
university and received a bachelor's of
science in business administration
and master of science and counseling her
highly anticipated book
next move best move transitioning into a
career love
will be released in spring of 2021.
kimberly b cummings thank you for
joining in 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good thank you so much for having me
i i love having you here thank you for
joining me where
in the world are you calling from right
now i am from newark
new jersey so literally i can see
manhattan from my window just to step
away
i love but that is where i land whenever
i come to visit my brother in new york
so it's a
has a special place in my heart kimberly
what i'd love to talk to you
most of all is your journey and talk
about you know your passions
and the different things you've
experienced and and really your passion
for diversity inclusion employer
outreach
talent acquisition everything that falls
into this realm obviously this is
insanely relevant forever but especially
in
in this past year when we've seen uh you
know what's been happening and the
the understanding of the gap that still
exists
and so what i would love to do is i
would love to educate myself and and
learn as much as i can
from your experiences and and let's just
get started tell me a little bit about
yourself and where
where you grew up and and how you got so
passionate about this stuff about this
topic
oh gosh so when i was born like we're
not going to start back that far
but um i was born and raised in a small
town in connecticut and i was one of a
few minorities in the entire town
um almost except for one grade where a
student came in from another um town i
was the one and only
um person who identified as being black
um so i've always been in an area
that did not necessarily have what i
like to call like visible diversity
of course there were diversity in like
socioeconomic status and other things
but visible like rape and ethnicity race
and ethnicity was not something that i
grew up having a lot of um outside of my
family so
now i really see how that's impacted my
life but during that time it's like i
just wanted to be around people who look
like me
um and how that transferred now is that
i've literally devoted my career
for 10 years now all into career and
leadership development
i'm like many folks and the early stages
of your career you kind of like stumble
like you try this it didn't work you
tried this it didn't work
but in my first job as a career
development counselor
i still remember the moment where i saw
someone
get a job as a direct result of working
with me it was actually an
internship and they ended up getting a
full-time offer and they stayed
and i was hooked because when you can
impact someone's career
like we spend 40 i spend sometimes 60
sometimes more hours a week working if
your work and your job
sucks like what do you think the rest of
your life is going to be like there's no
way to almost make up for that
significant amount of time
that you spend at work so what i quickly
realized working in career services is
that
women and underrepresented minorities so
black and latinx communities
sometimes were a little bit nervous
about coming to the office at career
services
um i was known as that person who's
going to give it to you straight i'm
always a straight shooter
um i used to joke and say like hey like
don't get me fired but this is really
what the issue is
and we need to fix this just let's just
go with me go with me we're going to
make it work and i noticed it was
working and
a lot of students used to refer their
friends and their friends of friends and
i was able to work on some really great
projects i presented at quite a few
conferences on my work and
slowly but surely the brand i created
um matched with some like me playing
around on the internet
really turned into a company so in 2013
i found a manifesto cell
which is all about career and leadership
development for women and people of
color essentially taking all the
resources that
i've learned and put together and
studied and
coached thousands of clients now on um
into a company where i proactively
serve those communities which i feel are
sometimes underserved
i used to say many times that we focus
so much on inclusion in the workplace
sometimes we forget about what diversity
means
and how that may not have prepared
someone
to be included just yet so what i what i
mean by that
sometimes women and people of color may
need preparation
prior to the inclusion and i feel like
that's where my company really comes in
handy like if you
get a professional maybe who is a
first-gen student
now in the workforce and you throw them
into a corporate fortune 100 company
they may not have anyone in their family
who knows what that environment is like
they may not have any friends who have
done that they need preparation on
literally how to navigate the world of
work so they can maximize that
opportunity
and that's what i really pride myself in
my little stick is that i help
women and people of color navigate the
world of work make more money and
position themselves as leaders
so that's like the the moderate short
and skinny kind of long version of what
i do
i i love that i have to go back to
something that you said that struck me
struggle court you mentioned in the you
know the origins of this you started out
by you know you were in these
organizations and you would find the
person you say you know what
don't get me fired but but you know
that's there's something that we need to
fix here
why why does that sentence need to be
first
so because i feel that's a part of an
issue right
i think sometimes um i've worked in
quite a few ivy league institutions so
there's like a little joke about how
like you don't know who's daddy
donated the building that you're sitting
in so hey sometimes you want to be
be very candid but you're a little
nervous sometimes because you don't know
who you're talking to
um or who their roommate is or whatever
else
but sometimes a lot of these
institutions may have a methodology
about how they work with folks any
organization that you generally have
career leadership development coaching
the governing body may have a way that
they speak to students
or their clients like non-students
alumni whoever it is
of how they like for you to pursue
sessions
and there's always a little bit of
nervousness about
creating and providing that feedback so
for instance i had a client
um who i was working with and uh for
lack of a
better way of saying it like her dress
her personal appearance
was the issue she presented as so much
older um and it made people not listen
to her
so she's out in the workplace applying
to jobs
doing the best you can has the
experience but
um she was prematurely gray so she had
about an
inch and a half of gray root showing um
her the blazers she used to wear
were that like super florally like
i was joking to like grandma's couchy
type of luck
um and i told her i'm like i really hope
you don't take offenseless but i need
you to brush it up
like you can literally go to cvs and get
a five dollar thing
just to like touch up the roots where
your part is i need you to go to walmart
or target and i don't care what the
blazer is but i want you to be a blank
slate
just get something plain black i don't
care the blacks match
um and when she looked at herself it
worked out her confidence because
confidence is the big part about being
in the workforce
and b it allowed people to not to look
past
all of the things we could of course say
that you shouldn't be looking at those
anyways
it is about the resume it is about all
these things but
we all know that we judge a book by its
cover so how can you present
something that is a little bit more like
the organization
that you're in or you know transferable
skills how can you speak about your past
experiences as it aligns the
organization
and appearance is a big piece of that
someone would have told me don't you
dare tell that woman to go dye her roots
but you best believe homegirl got a job
that next interview
she got the job there you go exactly so
kimberly tell me
tangibly practically how how do you go
about helping
helping these women because what you're
mentioning here first of all obviously
it's things that a lot of people would
be scared to even
say on a podcast right i mean these are
very very direct things that you know
a lot of biases that we just have as
human beings there's no way around
we have these biases and by being able
to confront them
and to understand yes this is how
society operates sometimes and
even if it might seem superficial you
know well that's the game that some of
us
you know have to play at least a little
bit to even get that opportunity so how
do you actually
grow this at scale and work with women
all over the place to to help build
both that confidence but also build that
leadership skill
as they as they navigate through the
workforce
so i think with any business one of the
things i've worked on is having a core
methodology of how i work with folks so
um oddly enough in june i have my own
book coming out where i kind of walk
through this process that i do with my
clients and
a lot of it starts with like
understanding who you are once you
understand who you are
what your unique value proposition is
similar to how like you know
entrepreneurs we have
a service a product or service we know
the transformation that it provides
why you need it what your problem is and
we kind of sell to you
to make sure people understand but in
the workplace if we stop thinking about
ourselves as brand we stop thinking
about the experience so once you get
clear on your experience
understanding your core values
understanding your strengths and growth
opportunities
putting a plan together a career
strategy to make sure you're attacking
those pops
and then working on how you position
yourself
through your relationships how you're
speaking about yourself
and kind of leveraging your own
authority in the workplace that's how
you really start to come back that's the
methodology that i have i use it
all whether you're one-on-one with me
whether you're in group programs whether
i'm at a speaking engagement i'm
generally teaching one of those core
pieces
and once professionals have that it
ultimately impacts their confidence
because the confidence many times is
what prevents you from rising to those
leadership positions because you're not
clear on who you are
your skills why you're there all of that
so it's just this circle that you kind
of have to fix
these core pieces of and that's how i
kind of leave my framework with my
client
so what it sounds to me is that you're
saying in the end one of the core just
examples is you know confidence but
you're not saying okay i'm going to
teach you how to be more confident
i'm going to help you you know i'm going
to help you
navigate through the different skills or
the different things that we that you
need to work on
that as a byproduct you're going to be
getting that confidence that's going to
exude
and and from there it's just a butterfly
effect right it's like a snowball going
but you have to first fix a foundation
or to work on a foundation to be able to
get to that type of impairment
exactly i think that in the workplace i
strongly believe that your confidence
and your ability to advocate for
yourself should come from
the skills and the experience you
provide anyone could walk and be like
yeah i could do that job it is not a
problem like and then they give you
crying at their desk because they can't
figure out how to do what it is
the confidence like when people talk
about your personal brand or
selling yourself or self-promotion like
that's not
like we're not just promoting something
that's bad we're promoting you
based upon the facts your results your
receipts of what you've accomplished
and if you've not accomplished things
that you're proud of yet well how can we
build a plan so you can do those things
so that you can rise to the level in
your career that you'd like to be a part
of
that that makes a lot of sense and how
do you then do this at scale so i
understand
you know i understand the notion that
you know if you sit one-on-one with
somebody and you work with them and you
talk through them you talk through
examples and you
you know follow them as a mentor
throughout a long time that works
how do you actually see because we're
talking about a wider a wider issue
right
a wider gap that you're that you're
looking to fix and obviously writing a
book is a part of it
how do you what strategies do we need to
employ perhaps even as a society
to to make this happen at scale
particularly for you know
given a specific demographic
perfect so i would say on a micro level
of course there's folks like me right i
wrote a book which is at scale
you'll be able to go to the bookstore
and pick that up as of june um i can do
one-on-one i also have group programs
that people can go through and i'm not
the only career and leadership
development coach out there there's
plenty of us who are trying to do this
good work right right
but i think on a macro level i think
when we're talking about
diversity equity and inclusion diversity
equity inclusion and belonging
whatever combination of words you'd like
to use i think a
it's bringing someone into that role and
giving them the resources
to truly do those things at scale
because when we talk about diversity
equity and inclusion it's not just
diversifying your workforce
it's diversifying the workforce but not
just
race and ethnicity there's also gender
there's socioeconomic status there's
background disabilities
veterans lgbtqia community there's so
many different ways to look at diversity
so understanding what does your
organization look like right now and
what is the ideal future state that
you'd like it to look like
diversifying coming in then it's how do
you retain those folks that you come in
that you bring in
and retaining them is really inclusion
so how do you make them feel included
and in a safe
environment at the workplace but then if
you're included it's all great to be
included
but if you're not getting promoted then
that's a whole other issue so it's also
the promotion piece how do you
get the talent keep the talent promote
the talent and that's really through
training and development programs
mentoring and all of this honestly take
some money
if you're going to hire a cdo and say
hey like
i'm so excited to have you here you're
going to sit on the board you're going
to
do these media things but if you don't
arm them with a budget and
team this work won't be able to get done
and i look at that as the macro because
if we're looking at the workforce every
company
is going to have someone who needs to
have someone there who's thinking about
this top of mind
maybe like in an entrepreneur smaller
sale company that they're not quite
there yet but we're talking about this
fortune
100 500 1000 they really need to be
armed
um with the budget to allow
their chief diversity officer or if it's
their people officer or hr
person to build a team that can really
focus on this
versus having people who are diversity
excited
in the business like do these side
projects because that's not enough
anymore we need a concerted effort
i think one of the things that one of
the amazing things that i've been
observing over this past year at least
is this intentionality
and this really you know company-wide
understanding or industry-wide
understanding that it's not enough to
just
you know say those words and say yes
we're into this or yes we promote this
but it's actually having figures within
the organization that are
there are champions of this that have
the budget that have the resources
and and accompany wide intentional
activity
to go and promote this it's not enough
to have one person say okay
you're responsible for this let us know
when you when you're done right that's
not how it works
and so i think that i think what you're
saying it makes makes perfect sense
of course i think that's why people have
kind of talked about performative
allyship lately right
everyone can do the big splashy thing
you can put a black square on your
instagram
you can have your ceo write this letter
that sounds so amazing
but what are you actually doing and
that's what
yeah people are tired of no action and
i'm excited to see over the next
few years i think with the black lives
matter movement with the lgbtq
i what lgbtqia community with
transgender rights
with the stop stop is what the run is
saying stop asian hate
um like there's so many different
campaigns for all different
um populations so when you have a team
that is able to focus on this and make
sure that each community
truly feels included and you actually
put actions behind these things
it's exciting and i think i'm a black
woman i identify as a black woman i
think people think well oh you know
maybe it's just like we've got to make
sure the black people are right or maybe
the latinx i'm like no no
no it is all of these groups who need a
strategic plan to make sure they're
included in the workforce
and that takes intentionality what is
perhaps one or two things that i as a
young entrepreneur and my friends were
young entrepreneurs
as we build or build our businesses and
as we scale
because at the end you know when you
talk about culture one of the things one
of the main themes of this
of the show is culture and building a
company and sailing and company
and one of the things that i've learned
is that you know to build good culture
you have to do it from the beginning
from the roots you can't come in after
you have a thousand people and say okay
everybody we're shifting directions this
is our new culture
right that doesn't work so what do i
need to do or what do i need to be
mindful of
to be to be successful in this domain
from the get-go
such a powerful question and
i think diversity is important from the
start it is very easy when you're
building coming from the ground up
to stay aligned to folks who
already understand are invested in the
idea
and i think it's important to diversify
the thought from the beginning
there are so many studies that show
diversity not only of course it's good
because quote unquote it's hot now
but it actually makes companies better
more
productive um generate more revenue and
just thinking about that i think it's
very easy to say
hey like me and my friends like we're
all at stanford
we're all in these classes we all get it
we're gonna launch this but how do you
pull in other groups to challenge your
way of thinking
to challenge how you do things and while
maybe it's two people building this
startup
but what does your board look like are
you able to diversify your board pull
someone from a different
industry a different socioeconomic
background different users
because even when we talk about coding
like there's so many
things on the back end of coding that
don't even align
to different um groups that will be
using the products like there's so many
studies like a lot of people were
blowing up in the news
um for what their code looked like
behind the scenes so i think is being
intentional about finding folks who are
different from you
um to help improve your product or
service i think that's the simplest way
to do it you know
i'm not looking for a three-person
startup to have one of those people a
chief diversity officer
but you know if it's it's three men how
about why not get a woman there
why not get if it's three white men why
not get a latinx or black black black
person there
like how there's so many different ways
to diversify from the beginning
i think it's just looking around you and
seeing
just opening your eyes so what is around
me like i'm a black woman
either say i have a whole bunch of black
friends but like when i'm working on
different things like how would a white
male feel about this when i do my
presentations in corporate america
i could be presenting to 1500 2 000
people and i guarantee
not all those people identify as black
latinx or a woman
so how is a male going to interpret this
how would i break down the different
races that are going to be on the call
how are they going to interpret and
intake this information
i think it's it's just being fully aware
of everyone who could be using your
product or service
kimberly this was insightful thank you
for spending your time with me i know
how busy you are
and and i can't wait to read the book
and thank you for everything thank you
for the great work that you're doing
and my favorite question that i have to
ask always
is three words you would use to describe
yourself or what are three words that
any of the women you've worked with
would use to describe kimberly becoming
i'm like and you told me you were going
to ask this and now i feel like i have
to still think
um i think that hey i'm resilient um i'm
someone who's always prepared to bounce
back
and pivot um i like to see myself as
credible in a career in leadership
development space i didn't just build a
career based upon
um my own career in a defined industry
i've always been working
across industries the entire time my
master's is in counseling
so i've learned career development
theory um that's why i do what i do
and i think that i'm ambitious um well i
know that i'm ambitious
i'm always excited to see what is the
next level to challenge myself
to create more impact kimberly thank you
very very much continue doing good for
the world
and and i look forward to keeping in
touch and seeking for your advice over
and over again thank you
yes indeed we'll talk soon michael yeah
you